[Music]
I'm the one
okay all right so obviously we're doing
this podcast because of
uh the the all the commentary news
coming out about what happened with
Andrew Tate a lot of people are texting
me asking me question Pat what's going
on DMS messages I said let me just go
live I'm going to be very brief I won't
be long I'll give you a couple things uh
I spoke to his Camp uh today
uh got a couple updates uh and then from
there we'll take it to you know we'll
see what's gonna happen next couple days
the reality of it is if you believe in
in coincidences today is March 31st
1999. 24 years ago today
you know a movie came out 24 years ago
today Kyle can you show it to him
24 years ago today Matrix came out how
Wild is that right to be thinking about
24 years ago today the movie Matrix came
out the day these guys are being
released now obviously you know what
kind of credence there is to this it's
purely a coincidence but it's very very
ironic that this movie came out 24 years
ago today a couple things I want to show
you the clip of them being released news
came out a couple hours ago of these
guys being released and if you see this
clip if you can go to Twitter go to the
Twitter video uh that's circulating
amongst what happened and what I want
you to look at is purely if you can
pause that go to the back there's no
audio because the way uh these guys did
it there was no audio I just want you to
look at Tristan's eyes and then I want
you to look at Andrew Tate's eyes so if
you want to press uh Play Let's Take a
look at this
there's the attorney
there is Tristan
now watch this
City eyes
look at Andrew's eyes pause a little bit
go back a little bit so we can see both
of the eyes
so if you play poker
or if you study body language you're in
the business of body language you're in
the business of studying your kids
your spouse your peers people you do
business with to see where they're at
what they're thinking
um I don't know I sense peace I sense
rage I sense strategy I sense next 15
moves and I sense an element of
unpredictability
uh but most importantly you can tell
these guys have gotten closer the last
three and a half months ever since
they've been in there since uh over the
day December 29th which is three months
since they've been in and uh you know
the biggest Factor right now with them
being out they're going to be on house
arrest I'll read your statements from
his lawyer here's what his lawyer said
earlier
uh uh uh the measure has been replaced
by the measure of house arrest okay the
court listened carefully to the lawyers
pleadings
and read carefully after the grounds
that no longer existed at this time no
one will flee the country from amongst
uh from uh the brothers they have
repeatedly expressed their intention to
work with the Judiciary and maintain it
they present it as I said earlier all
the guarantees they have children in
Romania they have a house in Romania
they have a lawsuit against them there's
no reason to flee the country the Tate
Brothers do not want to live a leader
Life as a fugitive in the country
they're just tired of wanting to rest
and these are some of the remarks being
made by the attorney right there to the
right
uh uh so that's kind of where they're at
right now what happens next nobody knows
there's a lot of different speculation
going on here about what's really going
on uh obviously this whole thing took
place after Tay to uh put out a tweet
calling out to uh Greta talking about
please provide your email address so I
can send a complete list of my car
collection and their respective enormous
emissions and as she responded back with
you know the small D energy and then
they went back and forth that thing got
570 000 retweets and then boom next
thing you know December 29 couple days
after that if not 24 hours after that uh
he gets arrested he and his brother get
arrested amongst the uh as well as the
other two girls that get arrested with
them and they could have done this in
April because if it's allegedly and
nothing's been charged you could have
done this since April so a lot of people
are sitting there wondering a few
different things in the states where I'm
at right now in America in the states uh
just yesterday the president got
indicted right so the president U.S got
indicted and wanted the biggest things
everybody's talking about here is how to
Justice System is using their power to
you know it's a weaponized justice
system they're trying to eliminate a
candidate which Trump could be going
against uh you know Biden and they don't
want him to be running and they can do
whatever they can to prevent this guy
this is the first time ever in the
history of United States where an
ex-president uh has been indicted so
these are all things going on we
impeached them twice he's indicted to
Russia the this that there's a lot of
people that are saying prove us what's
going on and Stormy Daniels hush money
from seven years ago why are you doing
it now you could have done it earlier is
this any other intentions you have to
want to do this in Manhattan a bunch of
people are commenting on this right now
we will see what happens there but uh
um
this is this is normal in other
countries this is not normal in America
but it's happened in America and a lot
of people are thinking this is similar
things that's going on with Tate uh
obviously over there uh where this takes
us nobody has any idea uh they were
trying to get these guys to go to jail
they tried their hardest uh their lawyer
we had around Tanya you know she was
here we had a very nice conversation
with her uh on how they're being treated
where they're at you know recently Tate
put out a tweet talking about the kind
of food they're giving him this is him
saying my food comes at 8 A.M noon and 5
p.m I have a plastic bag I use to try
and protect the food from insects I
spend my entire day destroying the Flies
and ants who get close to the meal in
accordance with Ramadan when the Sun
goes down I eat the stone cold food in
my cell by myself look final thoughts
before I wrap up and we'll do a podcast
us again next week but we got a lot of
stuff going on between now and next week
uh so I wanted to kind of comment today
before we go and do what I need to do
here with the kids
um this reminds me of a movie a movie
called The Count of Monte Cristo
uh The Count of Monte Cristo where he
goes away and sometimes when you go in
you're forced to think
and you're by yourself to reflect
to ponder to to talk to yourself you
don't have the distractions they don't
have access to their phones they're not
tweeting they're you know they're
talking to their camp in their Camp
tweets it out but these are not things
that they've been tweeting they've not
had access to their phones for since the
day they went into jail so this isn't
like they're looking at the internet
they're watching YouTube videos they're
doing this nope they don't have access
to any of that stuff even Andrew talked
about the possibility of wanting to
write a book
you when I went in the closest thing I
could think about with my own personal
life is when I went into military and I
was in boot camp uh for a few months man
I had a lot of thinking to do I I got
thinking about stuff family you know
issues in my own life you know what am I
going to be doing next what I'm doing
right what I'm doing wrong you tend to
get closer to God when I was in the
military
uh during those few months that is when
I got closer to God because you're
almost forced to reflect
you have no distractions think about all
the distractions you got on a daily
basis imagine if that was taken away
from you for three months what would
that be worth to you how many of you
watching this could go three months
taking all your distractions away one
hundred percent I mean you live in a
hotel without a TV on without phone
without anything for three months could
you do it and if you did do it what
would you do after a week
what would you do after three days what
would you do after two weeks you're
doing your walks your brother's there
and you guys can be thinking talking
about life talking about that talking
about mom talking about sister talking
about kids talking about God talking
about what matters talking about dreams
talking about things you did right
talking about things you didn't do right
all of these thoughts if you do it right
you come out wiser
so I almost think this was
Andrew is is obviously a man of Faith
the way he presents himself he's a man
of faith and I think Tristan is also a
man of Faith as well
this is a way where the man upstairs is
saying Hey listen
you've been doing what you've been doing
it's kind of time to get a little close
to me let's spend some time together so
all those prayers all those talks
um
the power of affirmations minus a
hundred percent silence pretty much for
90 days
some call that uh catastrophic but to
the right person that just may have been
exactly what you needed and now that all
these things about allegedly doesn't
come true and they can't charge them
they can't convict them
and these guys come out and they're
Freer and they're wiser more experienced
they've experienced a lot of different
things but nothing like this
there's a there's a certain upgrade Kai
that has taken place with these guys now
that nobody will be able to explain
except for them so
what happened next nobody knows they're
on house arrest is this a new clip you
got Kai this
go for it show it let's see what it is
[Music]
it's good to see him smiling
since last year
no
I believe in God
um I I truly believe that Justice will
be first in the end there is zero
percent chances
what are your plans for the next season
when I was in jail I did 7417 push-ups
[Music]
by the way you you sense the humility
do you sense the humility
I'm telling you this but life life does
uh there's certain things in life that
you change you know when you get married
when you have a kid when you get
introduced to God when you're forced to
be by yourself whether it's military
Jail uh death in the family death of a
close loved one all of these things
impact you in a different way
against
[Music]
there's no question about it uh
obviously there's going to be a lot more
things that will come uh but uh if if
the court had their way they had plenty
of chances to try to get as much as they
can by the way uh uh this is this is if
this goes in their favor Vice
Vice is going to have a lot of
explaining to do because they were a big
part of this and they they really tried
very hard to take these guys down but uh
again we'll see what happened these are
some of the thoughts that I had uh that
I want to share with you guys aside from
this there's nothing else that we have
we'll do podcasts again next week to
talk to you guys uh Kai anything else
you have on your end
that's right so stay tuned a lot of
crazy things are going on but uh we will
keep you updated we have a podcast
multiple next week as well as a live one
next Thursday night at the studio with
Rudy Giuliani and uh uh Dave Rubin live
uh if you haven't yet purchased the
ticket and you'd like to join us and
you're in South Florida uh text award
podcast to
310-340-1132 again text award podcast to
310-340-1132 we'll see you guys in South
Florida next Thursday if now we'll see
you on the podcast take care everybody
have a great weekend bye bye bye